what's going on reject nation it's great
out a half and it's John Humphrey here
so we're gonna watch the trailer today
for this Neill Blomkamp thingamajigger
oh boy oats studio experimental short
films volume 1 official trailer 2 have
you seen trailer 1 no nor have I let's
just go a trailer 2 so this is the one
people I've been sending over to us
lately do I'm excited I hope you two
lives again I got B who are you what are
you becoming Wow
these details are slipping away from the
one thing Wow
[Music]
for my I like
[Music]
you
halo-halo
[Music]
wow it's like Neil yeah Energon of the
Twilight - yeah right whoo let's watch
the first runner actually I don't know
why we didn't just start off with that
like Norma he had yeah I'm not watching
it they came here to exterminator will
dies we stay in lovely evening it even a
bit of the bonus place
Wow
[Music]
it looks like a really good sci-fi
channel of it but damn it I mean it has
all the neill blomkamp touches you know
the action sequences around your fire
Saul rifles crazy looking aliens the
halo homage imagery near futures that
looks lumber than yeah yeah yeah yeah
that looks really gritty it looks like
pure vintage neo Blanco this is his
studio I don't know really the story
behind this actually okay so the short
films yeah and they're hoping that you
know after volume 1 and volume 2 that
there might be enough interest and
actually creating a full-length feature
film which would be really neat yeah I
think I saw it as one of the great is it
kind of sort without district 9 got made
it is a short film first and then they
made a feature film like Peter Jackson
gone on board and stuff yeah I mean the
district I was a short film and I mean
he's been he makes a lot of shorts in
fact if you go on even on YouTube a
bunch of them are up and they're really
cool they're they're all kind of like he
has a style which is this sort of like
sci-fi but down-to-earth thing and
actually like as much as I wanted to see
alien 5 happen like I almost feel better
than he's doing something like this
because he still gots to go any Weaver
and there any still got to go agree that
they're going to Weaver most ladies able
to maybe make something new and try some
stuff I like the idea of experimental
short especially for a guy like him who
like I've listened to a lot of
interviews with him he's very open about
the fact that like certain parts of big
movie directing aren't as much as strong
suit so I'm excited I think this short
form content isn't mainly word is a big
strength slug you know you've got like
fairytale or fantasy in the sense of
like you know like a Guillermo del Toro
I feel like in the short films there is
that element there he does have a fairy
tale thing yeah I guess
you world there's a ritual fairytale
quality resentment bigger mythology I
feel in his short-films even an image of
the BMW Shores that we watched oh yeah
there's an N Dakota Fanning was in that
yeah yeah sure well even in the films -
I mean like you know as much as I I do
recognize their problematic things about
Elysium and about Chafee like I think
this guy is definitely a dude who has a
very strong vision and I'm always going
to be interested in what he's up yeah he
seems like a guy who who is more than
just you know a director like it seems
like he has his own little studio he's
interested in tech and in making you
know these experimental things so this
almost seems like it could have a lot of
pattern coming - cuz I heard it's
supposed to be three parts actually okay
three parts this must be twenty minutes
short films are released for free on
YouTube which I was great because I'm
like all right this is Neill Blomkamp
it's short films and not as big of a
budget but it's still him able to do
exactly what he want to do it's just a
free thing he's putting up on YouTube
and you know like for me he's one of
those directors that I feel is probably
more interesting when he's a more
unhinged story's more if the rains are
free for him to do whatever the hell you
want
and I thought thought about that in
terms of his movies too is like I almost
feel like yeah you could just do your
thing entirely and not have to worry
about you know the system will gather
because especially is like Elysium I was
like man I wish this is like your fifth
movie when you didn't have to listen to
anybody yeah or where you wouldn't have
like the limitations and certain things
Oh a total um so this yeah I'm just I'm
just super excited about yeah it looks
scary too yeah the other thing about it
like pretty on being like Austin and I
it looks kind of looks rather soon at
the aliens look kind of pretty scary I
feel there's going to be some real
suspense and there's some like
disturbing images the stuff with old
skeletons
yeah and like the aisles missing them
the one guy at like nerve Percy yeah
yeah like that's and that's something as
a Hornet I'm really excited to see him
big difference because they're jarring
elements of all of his movies but but
yeah like to have an actual like
aggressive horror element Emily you know
like Sigourney Weaver in there and and
there are some other people
is that a pop and I go beam errors in
this - I think you might have been in
the trailer but I heard Michael I feel
like Neill Blomkamp is destined to have
this thing where it's like okay you're
gonna make this huge property okay
you're not going to do that but the
people from that helped you it was
something cooler than that you know so
actually I guess district 9 was
originally the halo project that he was
supposed to do yeah yeah exactly so this
seems like this is the kind of thing I
would love to do something like I would
love a totally involved with a night
this someday who knows you work at Blum
house maybe one day you can get
something going over there make some
experimental horse and my shorts
alright guys well thanks for sending
these our way I'm pretty excited to see
and hopefully full reactions and it's 20
minutes long
I just want to enjoy anyway I want I'd
much rather just pull it up on the TV
and do a review I'm just yeah yeah I
hope these for you yeah well you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell - John Humphrey
on Twitter and Instagram go check out
our patreon got a lot of exclusive perks
and on video content on the remote over
pale jacket how it's my friends good day